a camera inside your fridge if you leave
for the store without checking what you
need text your fridge and it sends you
back a picture what's inside it's all
part of your smart home a mix of
products for sale and some futuristic
concepts this bathroom mirror from
Toshiba syncs with your watch and
monitors your health this kind of
wearable device has a vital signs or the
calories or last step and things like
that so you can just see those kind of
information as well as the schedule and
the weather so this oh maybe you say you
ate a little too much yesterday so you
can have a little lean lunch today if my
bathroom mirror told me that I need to
have a leaner meal this monitor above my
stove will show me visually how to cook
it and if I'm struggling with my meal I
can come down here call my mom and she's
gonna walk me through it but there are
two reasons why a fully connected home
may stay only in showrooms like this
instead of your own house one a common
language a common protocol for all these
machines to talk to each other and to
security how do you ensure that the home
stays private on the other hand who
really cares about my dirty laundry who
should be interested in hacking in your
domestic appliance who should be
interested in reading what you have in
your washing machine who should be
interested to start your dishwasher I
doubt somebody is interested in that it
may not be that interesting but first
thing in the morning I don't necessarily
want people to know how little I
exercised and how much I ate